President Trump comes out strongly in
favor of the Saudis after their alleged
murder of a dissident president from
submits his written answers in the
Muller investigation and nature magazine
doesn't actually care about nature this
is the Ben Shapiro show
it's the day before Thanksgiving folks
nobody wants to be here but we're here
with you anyway because we have to guide
you on the evening commute home or on
the moon morning commute to work that
you don't want to be at so we will be
here with you as you suffer through
traffic there is still a lot of news
happening in the lead-up to Thanksgiving
we will get to all of it in just one
second but first let me remind you that
if you are somebody who thinks about
going to restaurants a lot and who eats
too much prepared food and instead you
would like to cook at home but you don't
want all the work of having to go to the
grocery store come with your own recipe
buy too much of about various
ingredients and then cook it badly
instead you could be cooking like a
gourmet with blue apron blue apron
delivers farm-fresh ingredients and
step-by-step recipes to your door their
mission is to make incredible home
cooking accessible to everyone
blue apron does all the meal prep for
you here's how it works you choose
chef's designed recipes and they deliver
fresh seasonally inspired ingredients
you can cook incredible meals in as
little as 20 minutes every week at least
three recipes are built with your busy
schedule in mind where blue apron has
done the meal prep for you that means
the spices the sputter the sauces the
ingredients quick and easy recipe
options and blue apron offers a range of
recipes bursting with flavor I'm looking
at some of their recipes right now it's
stuff like beef and broccoli in cumin
spice sauce hot italian sausage pizza
smoky chicken and sweet potatoes it's
sweet potato bake I mean this stuff is
like top-line gourmet quality restaurant
stuff and you're gonna be making it at
home with your spouse with your kids
it's really fantastic go check it out
right now right now get your first 3
meals for free at blue aprons comm slash
Shapiro that is blue apron comm slash
Shapiro to get those first three meals
for free
whoo apron is indeed a better way to
cook folks around the office I've been
using blue apron for a long time and for
good reason
blue apron is a better way to cook blue
aprons comm slash up hero to get your
first three meals for free okay well we
begin today with some excellent news
romaine lettuce is not edible now there
are those of us who have known this for
years because it tastes like garbage and
I know there are a bunch of people like
those know I love romaine lettuce stop
lying to yourself you don't love romaine
lettuce you love all the stuff that's on
top of the romaine lettuce you like the
ranch dressing or you like the croutons
or e to like the panini that you chopped
up and put on the romaine lettuce to
make it edible but you didn't like the
romaine lettuce and you lying to
yourself is the cause of so much grief
in your life if you would just look into
your heart you would realize that you've
never wanted to eat romaine lettuce and
now you finally have the
excuse according to the New York Times
the warning came just as millions of
Americans were preparing for the biggest
food holiday of the year
people should not buy or eat romaine
lettuce restaurants should stop serving
it
anyone who has it on hand should throw
it out and clean the refrigerator
immediately this has always been the
policy at the Shapiro household romaine
lettuce has never entered within our
doors because this is not something that
I will tolerate as the man of the home I
will not tolerate anything that my food
eats being eaten by me there is a food
chain for a reason okay there has to be
an intermediate stop before the romaine
lettuce hits my stomach that
intermediate stop is an animal that once
ate the romaine lettuce this turn and
sweeping advisory issued by the Centers
for Disease Control and Prevention on
Tuesday afternoon two days before
Thanksgiving caught many people
off-guard but the agency said it was
acting out of an abundance of caution
after 32 people in 11 states fell sick
with a virulent form of e.coli a
bacteria blamed for a number of
foodborne outbreaks in recent years if
you don't know if the lettuce is romaine
or whether a salad mix contains remains
do not eat it and throw it away I agree
but this is the CDC saying it wash and
sanitize the Oersted or the drawers or
shelves and refrigerators where romaine
was stored officials said such measures
were necessary while they tracked down
the source of the contamination they
said a nationwide warning covering an
entire food type was unusual but not
unprecedented in 2006 they did this with
spinach Peter Cassell is a spokesman for
the FDA they said officials were in this
case mindful of the approach of the
Thanksgiving holiday they were afraid
that there would be some sort of giant
ecoli outbreak apparently the first
e.coli outbreak was identified on
October 8th has led to the
hospitalization of 13 people including
one person who developed kidney failure
so far no deaths I honestly okay when I
put aside the jokes for a second I
actually do kind of think this is
government overreach like the fact that
there have been 13 people in a country
of 340 million people who got sick from
eating romaine lettuce over the course
of six weeks does not seem to me like
the kind of crisis where you tell
everyone you cannot eat any romaine
lettuce ever it seems a bit of overkill
to me it also suggests that the
government has the capacity to prevent
all sorts of types of disease but listen
I'm not gonna look a gift horse in the
mouth and if they tell me that I have an
excuse not to eat romaine lettuce I'm
there so that is the big news today the
other big news that the President of the
United States has now made what can only
be described as a bizarre statement
about Saudi Arabia and
Trump has an unfortunate habit of saying
the quiet parts out loud you know
there's there's something in politics
where we all sort of know the truth
about the us's relationship with Saudi
Arabia the truth is that every president
of my lifetime has been too soft on the
Saudis President Reagan was too soft on
the Saudis George HW Bush told a wax to
the Saudis Bill Clinton was very soft on
the Saudis President Bush was very soft
on the Saudis Barack Obama was very soft
on the salaries and now President Trump
is very soft on the Saudis this has been
true for literally decades because the
ever since basically 1973 after the OPEC
oil embargo they've been a strategic
ally of the United States and that means
they've been able to get away with an
awful lot of stuff that we wouldn't
allow a normal ally to get away with
well we all know that but that doesn't
mean you're supposed to say the quiet
part out loud which is that we overlook
a lot of Saudi Arabia's human rights
violations because they're strategically
valuable to us well president Trump
never a fan of leaving anything unspoken
came out with a statement yesterday with
regard to the Saudi Arabians alleged
murder of Jamal cachaca Shah he was a
longtime critic of the Saudi regime he
was largely sympathetic to the Islamic
Muslim Brotherhood so he wasn't any sort
of moderate Muslim for example the Saudi
government according to the CIA had
cushaw he murdered at the Saudi embassy
in Turkey at the specific direction of
Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
according to the to the Washington Post
now bin Salman has been the supposed to
reformer in Saudi Arabia who is making
overtures toward the United States
overtures toward Israel and was a strong
strategic ally of the Trump
administration so President Trump put
out a statement with regard to the
khashoggi
murder based on this new report that CIA
had said the Saudi Arabian government
was responsible for it and in particular
Prince Mohammed bin Salman and his
statement is in equal parts true false
and bad like really there's a lot here
so the the sort of framework that you
should understand about about the
statement about Saudi Arabia is several
things can be true at once one Saudi
Arabia is a terrible terrible human
rights violator they do terrible things
on a regular basis they target
dissidents they chop people's hands and
heads off in the kingdom still they do
not allow people of the Judaic faith to
enter the country and there are a lot of
problems with Saudi Arabia in Saudi
Arabia has a lot of issues they treat
women like a garbage and have for
decades they have funded terrorism in
the past a
all of this is true they are not a force
for good on the world stage that's point
number one point number two Saudi Arabia
is a very important counterweight to
Iranian influence in the region Iran is
significantly more dangerous worldwide
and regionally than Saudi Arabia ever
was Saudi Arabia has formed the de facto
alliance with Jordan Egypt and Israel
against the rising Iranian influence and
they are an important strategic ally and
partner for the United States in the
region so both of these things can be
true one Saudi Arabia violates human
rights and two Saudi Arabia is an
important strategic Ally against a much
more threatening power in Iran and
number three you don't have to say out
loud that number one is okay right
you're not supposed to say number one is
okay they can be a strategic Ally and
still you can take action to punish them
when they violate human rights and also
you don't have to go out there and
praise the violation of human rights or
shrug at the violation of human rights
because that has some pretty negative
consequences such as the the feeling on
the part of people who are our allies or
strategic partners that they can get
away with pretty much anything so long
as they pleased us economically that's
not something the United States wants to
put out there in the world now again
that is the quiet part out loud right
Barack Obama did the same thing Barack
Obama was essentially the PR agency for
the Iranian government Barack Obama did
heavy work for Russia's Vladimir Putin
one of the worst dictators on the planet
brutal human rights violator who Barack
Obama handed over control of Syria to in
the wake of saying that he had a redline
with regards to use of chemical weapons
in Syria Barack Obama did the same thing
with the Cuban government who went over
there and he played kissy face with the
Castro's even though the Castros are
some of the worst human rights violators
of the last half-century so he did all
that and that was real bad it's not
better when Trump does any of that okay
so here is president from stateman you
can tell the president Trump was heavily
involved in writing this because it has
a lot of exclamation points and it is
phrased exactly as president Trump would
phrase it so this one is pretty genuine
here's what President Trump had to say
he said the world is a very dangerous
place right which is which is his way of
saying because the world is a very
dangerous place we have to look the
other way when some of our allies do bad
stuff again this is not untrue and we
all sort of know it it's also not a
great thing to say out loud if you're
the President of the United States and
you're supposed to take human rights
seriously he then gives a paragraph of
truth about Iran he says the country of
Iran as an example is responsible for a
bloody proxy war against Saudi Arabia in
Yemen
trying to destabilize a rocks fragile
attempted democracy supporting the
terror group Hezbollah in Lebanon
propping up dictators ashore Assad in
Syria who has killed millions of his own
citizens and much more likewise the
Iranians have killed many Americans and
other innocent people throughout the
Middle East Iran states openly and with
great force death to America and death
to Israel Iran is considered the world's
leading sponsor of terror so far so good
although this is true Iran is
extraordinarily dangerous despite Iran's
regional ambitions maybe because of
those regional ambitions the Obama
administration went out of its way to
lie on behalf of the mullahs handing
billions of dollars clear the pathway to
a nuclear bomb for them and which is why
it's particularly galling when you see
members of the Obama administration
suddenly coming out of the woodwork to
condemn Trump for playing nice
with the Saudis and for covering for the
Saudis when the Obama administration did
that after the Iranians forget about the
the the Saudis killing dissidents the
Iranians killed American soldiers in
Iraq like five hundred American soldiers
in Iraq are dead because of her because
of the Iranian government and the Obama
administration played nice with them
which is significantly more dangerous
than just on its geostrategic plane much
more dangerous for the Obama
administration to play nice with the
world's leading state sponsor of
terrorism than it is for the Trump
administration to play nice with the
human rights violating evil dictatorship
in Saudi Arabia who also happens to
strategically align with us in certain
valuable ways and does not have the
military capacity to extend its regional
influence beyond Yemen basically
President Trump then continues he says
on the other hand Saudi Arabia would
gladly withdraw from Yemen if the
Iranians would agree to leave they would
immediately provide desperately needed
humanitarian assistance
additionally Saudi Arabia has agreed to
spend billions of dollars in leading the
fight against radical Islamic terror
well may be right this is where we start
to get into the president playing PR
agent for the Saudis and it's a really
bad look the fact is that in the
American southeast strategic alliance we
are the powerful partner
we are the 400-pound gorilla we're the
most powerful country in the history of
the world
Saudi Arabia needs us a lot more than we
need Saudi Arabia if we were to say to
the Saudis listen guys you need to clean
up your act or we're gonna cut off aid
Saudi Arabia doesn't have a lot of
choices available to them at that point
if we were to say to them listen you're
going to need to create all of these
human rights reforms or away goes your
military support they wouldn't have a
lot of choices in the matter because
again Saudi Arabia is not militarily
strong except the you know
States has troops stationed in Saudi
Arabia and it's basically been the
mission of the US government to protect
the strategic sovereignty of Saudi
Arabia only get a little bit more into
this in just one second first let's talk
about you dressing well so you're gonna
go to Thanksgiving and let's face it
you're gonna look like a schlub but
there's no reason you need to look like
a schlub every other day of the year you
don't need to wear those fat pants every
other day of the year instead you should
be getting a tailored suit that makes
you look like James Bond Indo Chino
makes the best suits on the market they
are tailor-made for you they have a huge
variety of fabrics colors and patterns
it makes it Enzo Chino super stylish
there's no longer any excuse for wearing
a bad suit in the ill-fitting suit you
go to the you go to the local department
store and pick something up off the rack
and it hangs on you like a pair of
drapes instead go get a tailored suit
Indo Chino makes suits in shirts to your
exact measurements for an unparalleled
fit and comfort guys love the options to
personalize the details including lapel
lining pockets buttons writing your own
monogram it's really cool I've been to
the Indo Chino showroom here in Los
Angeles I went and I had them
personalized the suit just for me it
really does feel like you're coming from
a James Bond movie it's super cool or if
you don't have a showroom clothes
instead you can do measurements at home
yourself and shop online in Indo Chino
comm you can choose your fabric inside
it out choose your design customizations
submit your measurements and then just
watch as the complements roll in
November is Black Friday and Friday
season meaning that 2018 s lowest prices
are here up to 70% off everything the
theme is all about stepping out from
backstage it's time to make an entrance
ok guys it is time for you to look good
that 70% off the regular price for a
made-to-measure suit again my listeners
receiving that Black Friday pricing by
using promo code Shapiro at checkout and
shipping is free
that's Indo Chino com promo code Shapiro
for up to 70% off Indo Chino kaam promo
code Shapiro for up to 70% off alright
so back to you president Trump statement
so he's complimenting Saudi Arabia and
talking about how we need them he says
after my heavily negotiated trip to
Saudi Arabia last year the kingdom
agreed to spend and invest 450 billion
dollars in the United States this is a
record amount of money it will create
hundreds of thousands of jobs tremendous
economic development and much additional
wealth for the United States of the 450
billion 110 billion will be spent on the
purchase of military equipment from
Boeing Lockheed Martin Raytheon and many
other great US defense contractors if we
foolishly cancelled these contracts
Russia and China would be the enormous
beneficiaries and very happy to acquire
all of the
newfound business it would be a
wonderful gift to them directly from the
United States okay that's not exactly a
great argument okay if your argument is
that we are about to make a lot of money
in an economic deal so it's okay if
Saudi Arabia kills dissidents this is
patently immoral and if Barack Obama had
said it we would be saying exactly that
at the time hey by the way President
Trump doesn't feel this way about China
right he said that we have to declare a
trade war on China which is gonna be a
lot more damaging to the United States
economy then losing out on some defense
contracts with Saudi Arabia the
president says we need to declare our
trade war on China for moral reasons and
strategic reasons I think there is some
truth to that but I don't think that he
can maintain those positions separately
though that China bad Saturday be a good
that just that doesn't hold but here's
where he gets to the really bad stuff
the president's in the statement he says
my crime against Jamal cushaw he was a
terrible one and one that our country
does not condone indeed we have taken
strong action against those already
known to have participated in the murder
murder
after great independent research we now
know many details of this horrific crime
we've already sanctioned 17 Saudis known
to have been involved in the murder of
mr. Kershaw II and the disposal of his
body representatives of Saudi Arabia say
that Jamal cushaw he was an enemy of the
state and a member of the Muslim
Brotherhood my decision is in no way
based on that this is an unacceptable
and horrible crime King Salman and Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman vigorously
deny any knowledge of the planning or
execution of the murder of mr. Kashani
our intelligence agencies continue to
assess all information but it could very
well be that the crown prince had
knowledge of this tragic event maybe he
did and maybe he didn't very weird
statement in a presidential statement
maybe he did and maybe he didn't listen
his CIA said he did so there's that but
maybe he did maybe he didn't mm-hmm says
that being said we may never know all
the facts surrounding the murder of mr.
Jamal Khashoggi now let's beef it let's
be straight about this president Trump
makes these sorts of denials all the
time you remember in Helsinki he met
with Vladimir Putin
and then Putin said I've eaten all cocky
on election haha
and President Trump came out and said
either tell you the president Putin was
extremely strong and powerful in his
denial so President Trump will buy
denial from people who he thinks treat
him nicely and the same thing is true
from Mohammed bin Salman and the and the
Saudi Crown Prince I mean the Saudi King
he'll buy all of that if it fits his
fits his preconceived notions with that
said it is
a particularly useful line not only is
it useful it's it's it's not moral it's
not moral to undercut your own CIA's
finding that a specific murder was
ordered at the direction of a key ally
and then you're like well maybe it
happened maybe it didn't I didn't know
really there I think that that that is
not a good thing for the President of
the United States to be saying and again
I was all up you know on Obama when when
he when he did very similar sort of
stuff and we got to Obama in just a
second and the leftist blowback but
president Trump's statement continues he
says in any case our relationship is
with the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia they've
been a great ally in our very important
fight against Iran the United States
intends to remain a steadfast partner of
Saudi Arabia to ensure the interests of
our country Israel and all other
partners in the region it is our
paramount goal to fully eliminate the
threat of terrorism throughout the world
I understand there are members of
Congress who for political or other
reasons would like to go in a different
direction and they are free to do so I
will consider whatever ideas are
presented to me but only if they are
consistent with the absolute security
and safety of America after the United
States Saudi Arabia is the largest
oil-producing nation in the world
they've worked closely with us and have
been very responsive to my request to
keeping oil prices at reasonable levels
so important for the world as president
of the United States I intend to ensure
that in a very dangerous world America
is pursuing its national interests and
vigorously contesting countries that
wish to do us harm
very simply it is called America first
so America first means that we have to
basically greenlight Saudi Arabia
killing dissidents that is overstated
and this is the point that I'm making
you can side with Saudi Arabia against
Iran you can suggest that we need to
continue military support for Saudi
Arabia you can say that they are a
strategic Ally but what you can't do and
what you shouldn't do as president of
the United States is pretend that murder
of a dissident is not a big deal or
suggest that the murder of the dissident
is not attributable to the Saudi
government because maybe the CIA made a
mistake who knows good be whatever like
that is not a good look for any
President of the United States and so it
is not completely out of left field or
incorrect when the Washington Post
criticizes the president saying that he
president Trump's response to the brutal
murder of journalist Jamal khashoggi is
a betrayal of long-established American
values of respect for human rights and
the expectation of trust and honesty and
our strategic relationships now here is
where we start to get to the dicey
territory so first of all we'll finish
with president Trump's commentary and
then we'll get to the dicey territory
which is people on the left
we're going after President Trump in a
way they never went after Barack Obama
for his ties with Iran with Cuba with
Vladimir Putin right I mean that stuff
is really really hypocritical and not
only hypocritical sets up a standard
that essentially suggests the only
reason they're going after Trump is
sheer partisan politics over this stuff
that he said the he said the quiet part
out loud and he wasn't supposed to do
that for whatever reason okay with that
said here was president Trump State so
President Trump at this point is almost
trolling he says the reason that we are
not doing anything about Saudi Arabia is
it's America first I don't do all I do
is focus on this country and making
great deals for this country I don't
focus on making great deals for myself
because I don't care anymore
so Saudi Arabia has nothing to do with
me what does have to do with me is
putting America first okay so and the
idea is that America's interests require
us to do this and here's the point
America's interest do not actually
require us to greenlight the murder of
dissidents by strategically partnered
governments that doesn't actually
require us to to do that that is the
point that I'm making over and over here
and when President Trump says he's not
going to destroy the economy on the
basis of them murdering a citizen of
their country well you know again the
idea that we're gonna destroy the
economy if we sanction the Saudis a
little bit is just absurd and I'm not
going to tell a country that's spending
hundreds of billions of dollars and has
helped me do one thing very importantly
keep oil prices down so that they're not
going to a hundred and 150 dollars a
barrel right now we have oil prices in
great shape I'm not going to destroy the
world economy and I'm not going to
destroy the economy for our country by
being foolish with Saudi Arabia okay so
you know again the idea that we are
supposed to greenlight bad Saudi
behavior because they keep the oil
prices low that's been true for decades
but when the president of the United
States says it out loud it makes it
sound as though the United States is
somehow in thrall to the oil prices in
Saudi Arabia which is really bad stuff
the president should not be saying this
and this led to Mike Pompeo the
Secretary of State being grilled he's
being grilled at the State Department he
was asked you know does America first
mean putting cash ahead of human rights
so does the America first agenda means
putting US business interests
head of human rights concerns the United
States took a very strong response we
have sanctioned 17 individuals in
connection with that investigation we
are we are at the same time committed to
making sure that we place America's
national security interests and all the
actions that take place in the context
of doing the right thing to make sure
that America continues to thrive and
grow and when we do that the world is
better off for it - and the Middle East
is better off as well okay now as I say
I am NOT opposed to the Trump
administration's general policy with
regard to Saudi Arabia in fact I think
that that general policy is largely
correct but with all of that said
they're opening themselves up to charges
that they don't care about human rights
which seems to be somewhat true and to
the idea that President Trump is putting
simple trade deals above basic morality
President Trump seems to be saying that
himself that is a serious problem now
with that said we're gonna get to the
left's response which is entirely
hypocritical completely politically
driven and not driven in any real way by
serious objections to what President
Trump actually did I'll explain that in
just one second first let's talk about
your sleep quality so there's nobody on
the planet like you why would you buy a
generic mattress built for somebody else
helix sleep has no belt to sleep quiz it
takes two minutes to complete they use
the answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
or a hot sleeper whether you like a
plush or a firm bed with helix there's
no more guessing at no more confusion
just go to helix sleep calm slash man
take that two minutes sleep quiz they'll
match you to a mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life
it really is spectacular I mean these
mattresses are really good my wife and I
have one we took the two minutes sleep
quiz and then we got the mattress it
came in a box we unwrapped it it
inflated right in front of us we toss it
on the bed frame and it was then good to
go it's really a terrific product and
right now helix is offering up to 125
bucks off all Nattrass orders again up
to 125 bucks off at helix sleep comm
slash Ben that's helix sleep comm slash
Ben for 125 dollars off your mattress
order go check it out right now
helix sleep comm slash man they also
have a 10 year warranty you got to try
it out for a hundred nights risk-free
you really got nothing to lose and
everything to gain in terms of sleep
quality these mattresses are so good I
got one for my sister for her wedding
she loves it it's really great helix
sleep calm slash man for a hundred
twenty-five bucks off your mattress
order okay so the left response to
President Trump is
critical and absurd those of us who
called out President Obama for his
insane his insane support for the
Iranian regime have every right to now
say that the President of the United
States as a Republican should not be cow
telling to the Saudi government but the
same people on the Left who were who
were paying homage to President Obama
for going to the Muslim world and
suggesting that America was responsible
for all of the Muslim world's problems
the the entire left that was fine with
President Obama bowing in front of the
Saudi King remember that picture the
entire left that was totally fine with
Barack Obama playing PR agency for the
Iranians now they're very upset that
President Trump is basically doing the
same thing with regard to an actual
strategic partner not the leading world
sponsor of global terrorism so for
example you have Samantha power Samantha
power is the former UN Ambassador and to
- the - for the Obama administration and
Samantha power basically here's what she
tweeted out let me let me actually find
the exact tweet because it really is
quite absurd here it is so the exact
tweet that Samantha power sent out was
this it is a mean and nasty world but
Trump siding with the meanest nastiest
out there whether to tear it Sisi Putin
or assassin MBS IV Mohammed bin Salman
will leave the world even nastier this
statement is a green light for would-be
murderers in countries that have things
Trump thinks we need Samantha power you
and your administration said that there
was a red line in Syria with use of
chemical weapons then you turned over
the entire country to Bashar Assad and
the Russians use Samantha power were
part of an administration that turned
over half Iraq to Isis you Samantha
power we're part of an administration
that played PR agency for the Iranian
regime the leading world sponsors of
terrorism you Samantha power were
responsible for an administration that
kowtow to the Cuban government which
jails dissidents for decades and
tortures them you cement the powers were
responsible for a rise of the Chinese
government a solidification of that
Chinese government this is the part
where where I start to say okay so are
they really angry at Trump because Trump
did something wrong like I'm in great
form because Trump did something wrong
here or are they angry at Trump just
because he's Trump are they angry at
Trump because he said the quiet part out
loud because he did exact
what the Obama administration did except
against the Iranians and because they
don't like Trump personally it seems to
me a lot more of the latter so for
example look at this insanity from
representative Steve Cohen Steve Cohen
is Congress person from Tennessee and
here he is suggesting that President
Trump was paid off by the Saudis that's
why he's doing this because we need to
know if foreign money being given to our
president and the words family affects
our foreign policy that's why the
Amaya's clause was put in the
Constitution to see to it that the
president deals first for the benefit of
the country and not for the benefit of
himself hey then this is absurd even
Brianna Keilar over at CNN was like you
have no evidence of this whatsoever and
then he tried to talk over her but again
the reality is that the Obama
administration did this with Iran in a
much more spectacular and dangerous way
Marc Thiessen had a column back a couple
of years ago it's specifically talking
about the kinds of lies that were being
promoted by the Obama administration
here is what he says he says the Obama
administration told Congress it would
not allow Iran access to US financial
institutions issued a special license
allowing Iran to do exactly that
unsuccessfully pressured US banks to
help Iran lied to Congress and the
American people about what had been done
admitted in internal emails that these
efforts exceeded u.s. obligations under
the nuclear deal sent officials
including bank regulators around the
world to urge foreign financial
institutions to do business with Iran
and promised that they would get nothing
more than a slap on the wrist for
violating US sanctions how bad is this
says Marc Thiessen removal words Obama
and Iran and replace him with Trump and
Russia and imagine the outrage that
would ensue over the same revelations
but of course that's exactly right
and the Obama administration
acknowledged at the time that they were
lying to the American people according
to Paul Farhi at the Washington Post
back in 2016 one of President Obama's
top national security advisers LED
journalists to believe in misleading
timeline of US negotiations with Iran
over a nuclear agreement and relied on
inexperienced reporters to create an
echo chamber that helped sway public
opinion to seal the deal according to a
lengthy magazine profile Ben Rhodes the
deputy national security advisor for
strategic communications told The New
York Times Magazine he helps promote a
narrative that the administration
started negotiations with Iran after the
supposedly moderate Hassan rouhani was
elected president in 2013 in fact the
administration's negotiation actually
began earlier with the country's
powerful Islamic faction the framework
for the agreement was hammered out
before
money was even elected so they were
lying to the American people and they've
been continuing to play defense for the
Iranian government ever since John Kerry
no less than four months ago was in Iran
basically telling the Iranians weighed
out president Trump maybe after he's
gone we can come back to you he's going
out there and performing his own foreign
policy the Iranian backing Obama
administration officials have ripped
into for example the Israelis for
pointing out that Iran has not in fact
been compliant with the nuclear deal
there's a note on his complaint we love
Iran Iran's doing great saying the idea
coming from these folks that the Trump
administration is doing anything new or
extraordinarily terrible here is just a
lie the only difference is that Trump
says stuff out loud that Obama did
quietly that is the only difference here
and the difference that Saudi Arabia
actually is a strategic partner to the
United States in a way that Iran is not
this is not what about ISM here okay
there's not me saying that it's okay for
Trump to do what he did about khashoggi
because Obama did the same thing with
regard to Iran the point that I'm making
here is that Trump was wrong to say what
he said about Khashoggi but Saudi Arabia
is more of a strategic Ally than Iran
ever was and for all of the folks on the
Left to be proclaiming from the high
hills the high ground on foreign policy
is insane ridiculous and unbaked
they have no capacity to do this in any
honest way it's just absurd it's just
absurd and speaking of just absurd
there's an article from The New York
Times about President Trump today
talking about how President Trump
supposedly wanted the DOJ to indict and
prosecute Hillary Clinton and former FBI
director James Comey according to the
New York Times President Trump told the
White House Counsel in the spring that
he wanted to order the Justice
Department to prosecute two of his
political adversaries his 2016
challenger Hillary Clinton and the
former FBI director James becoming
according to two people familiar with
the conversation the lawyer
Donald McGann rebuffed the president
saying that he had no authority to order
a prosecution mr. McGann said that while
he could request an investigation that
too could prompt accusations of abuse of
power to underscore his point again ad
had White House lawyers write a memo for
Trump warning that if he asked law
enforcement to investigate his rivals he
could face a range of consequences
including possible impeachment so the
left has been going nuts over this how
could president Trump have ever
suggested prosecuting Hillary Clinton or
James Comey
you know what the answer is the answer
is the same as the answer is with regard
to the Saudi thing presidents Trump's
has a lot of stuff out loud that a lot
of other people say quietly president
Trump's is a lot of stuff and considers
a lot of stuff that his job does not
allow for President Obama did it quietly
and so we pretend that meant that he was
filled with dignity and honor President
Trump says this stuff out loud and
therefore this means that he is the
greatest tyrant this side of Genghis
Khan right this is really how the media
play it remember President Obama had his
Attorney General act as his wingman that
is the statement of his own attorney
general he declared an executive
privilege on behalf of that Attorney
General and he was held in contempt by
Congress no one at the IRS was ever
prosecuted for the targeting of
conservative groups but Obama did it
quietly he didn't say it out loud and
that meant that he was filled with
dignity and honor and some folks kind of
freed her store over at the nation no no
I'm sorry at the Atlantic he said well
you know you're making excuses for a
president Trump on this story no I'm
just telling the truth
I'm president Trump which is president
Trump's is a lot of crap most of it
never sees the light of day most of it
never turns into policy because as I say
President Trump says a lot of crap I'm
not gonna take a statement from
president Trump threatening things with
the same seriousness as a statement from
President Obama threatening things why
because Obama was a much more subtle
politician who didn't say the quiet part
out loud
president Trump always says things out
loud there has not yet been a thought
that occurred to President Trump that
did not then exit his face within a
millisecond so in President Trump says
stuff no I'm not gonna take it as
seriously as I would from President
Obama because Obama actually considered
the stuff that came out of his face and
that meant and when he issued a threat
it was actually dangerous when Trump
issues a threat it's mostly Trump just
saying things and these folks who are
saying I'm supposed to treat Trump
exactly like Obama like I have a
functioning prefrontal cortex they're
not going to that's silly it's like
saying that I'm supposed to treat my two
and a half year old son the same way
that I treat my wife when they make
pronouncements on things like no there
are different people with different
capacities that's not a thing hey
president Trump is great at a good many
things he is not great at not saying
things right he says a lot of stuff and
allow that stuff never materializes so
the fact that he's had a crazy thing
that never materialized forgive me if
I'm not going to go crazy over that in
the same way that I would for President
Obama because President Obama was a much
more serious human being when it came to
saying things that were correlated with
his policy go back and look at all the
statements
Trump is made and see how they've
correlated with sexual policy the answer
is not very well these statements that
President Obama made with regard to his
hard core policy that stuff correlated
pretty well with exactly what he was
trying to do and we'll get to President
Obama in just a second but first let's
talk about how you can relax over this
long Thanksgiving weekend hey I know
you're stressed out from the year right
it's been a long year let's be real I
mean it's been 1,000 news cycles since
the beginning of this year and I'm sure
that your business has made you stressed
out too well a great way to relax feel
better when you get back to work on
Monday is over the weekend why don't you
go check out zeal zeal allows you to get
a massage in the comfort of your own
home with your back hurts from running
after the kids your muscles are sore
from working out or just stressed zeal
brings you same-day in-home massages
with the best licensed and vetted
massage therapist directly to your home
think getting an in-home massage is
something available only to people who
are wealthy and famous like me wrong
wrong zeal is available to you it's a
perfect solution for anyone who wants a
high quality massage in the convenience
of your own home you just go to zeal
comm where you go to their zeal iPhone
or Android app that is ze e Elcom and
you select from top local licensed
pre-screened massage therapists choose
your favourite technique gender
preference time and location for your
massage Co will send you one of their
10,000 licensed massage therapist
massage table music supplies
scheduling booking payment is fast and
easy the tip is included it's available
around the clock
bring the spot to you trial today really
like today there on demand you can have
the best massage of your life in your
own homeles yield today to help you get
started our listeners right now get a
special deal 25 bucks off their first
in-home massage with promo code ben i
mean go check this out right now it's a
great deal ze Elcom promo clip Ben and
you get a special offer 25 bucks off
your first in-home massage go check it
out right now zeal calm and use that
promo code Ben to let them know that we
sent you okay so I want to talk about
President Obama and his pronouncements
on politics and why you should probably
take them more seriously than whatever
thing Trump said a year ago that never
got implemented in policy we'll talk
about that in just a second first you're
gonna have to go and subscribe $9.99 a
month allows you to subscribe when you
do you get the rest of the show live the
rest of Andrew Klavan show live dress to
Michael Noel's show live you also get to
access new episodes of the conversation
which come out on a routine basis here
at the Daily wire like lots of good
stuff happening plus
when really stately wire backstage you
want to ask us questions you get to do
that when I have my mailbag on Fridays
you get to ask questions that I will
answer all of these things happen for
you when you spend $9.99 a month over at
daily wire and when you get the annual
subscription ninety-nine dollars a year
you get this the very greatest in
beverage vessels the leftist here's hot
or cold tumbler go check it out right
now it is fantastic you could have been
sipping this for Thanksgiving if you had
actually bothered to get your
subscription like three weeks ago
instead you will suffer through
Thanksgiving with your relatives not
infused with the intelligence and
bravery that this tumbler provides you
but you don't have to make the same
mistake for Christmas so make sure that
you go get a subscription right now we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so President Obama as I say you
know that there's been a lot of talk
about how seriously should we take
president Trump and the biggest problem
for president Trump generally has been
the dude says a lot of stuff which is
one of the reasons why President Trump
should never testify in the Moller
investigation because the guide like
things fall out of his face at the same
rate as things fall out of a newborn
babes face after you breastfeed them
like president Trump just says many many
things and if you are his lawyer the
last thing that you want is him spitting
up all over our mother it's really not
something they're interested in Robert
Mozer starts to burp and then all of a
sudden Trump just vomits out a bunch of
stuff like that would not be smart so
instead he has issued a bunch of written
responses according to the New York
Times President Trump
laid out for special counsel his defense
in the investigation into possible ties
between his associates and Russia's
election interference the president's
lawyers said in a statement on Tuesday
the details of Trump's responses were
not immediately clear his lawyers said
that now that he'd handed over his
answers to questions from the special
counsel the time had come to end the
investigation this seems about right
once he's given his answers I'm not sure
exactly what more there is to do here
okay all of that said that is smart work
by his lawyers of course we want written
answers and outspoken answers because
President Trump says a lot of stuff you
know who else says a lot of stuff but
means it seriously Barack Obama
this gives Trump a bit of an advantage
in the Trump versus Obama sort of
sweepstakes that's because Selena's
Ito's description of from that you take
him seriously but not literally is
pretty accurate right because from says
a lot of stuff there's a lot of we all
know what he means
there's a lot of that with President
Trump with Obama we know what he means
because he says what he means and when
he says what he means we take it
seriously because he is a considered
politician very smooth very rhetorically
sound and therefore when he attacks
Americans he disagrees with morally or
his rubes or his idiot or his racists we
ought to take that seriously because he
is speaking for the Democratic Party in
a way that Trump never spoke for the
Republican Party it's really kind of
fascinating people say that Trump is
speaking for the moral heart of the
Republican Party listen I was afraid of
that in 2016 I said I didn't want Trump
to soul suck the Republican Party and
make it so that every one of his
utterances became the new de facto
conservative position I don't think that
has happened I think that if you ask
most Republicans what they think of
President Trump most Republicans will
say yeah kind of like the guy and if you
ask them about his more ridiculous
statements
and you are honest about asking and
you're not just you know a leftist
trying to do a gotcha what they will say
is yeah that was pretty bad he probably
shouldn't have said that but you know
what I don't look to President Trump for
my moral bearings I look for him to get
things done and that's what most
Republicans would say when they are
looking for kind of thought leaders
president Trump is not a person they go
to this particularly true for young
Republicans by investigative and polling
data in any case President Obama is
different president Trump does represent
the heart and soul of the Democratic
Party in a way that Trump actually
doesn't and President Obama was asked in
an interview about denial of global
warming and listened to his statements
about Americans generally and Americans
who don't agree with him on his policy
prescriptions with regard to global
warming the reason we don't do it is
because we are still confused blind
shrouded with hate anger racism mommy
issues okay so he was asked specifically
about global warming and he said the
reason that we don't invest in climate
change policies is because we're
confused blind shrouded with hate anger
and racism UNAM and nominations in other
words if you don't agree with me then it
is because you are confused blind
shrouded with hate anger racism and
mommy issues he says I mean we are
fraught with stuff and so if in that
case the single most important thing we
have to invest in is not all look like a
huge supporter of science and
technological research and social
science I'm people call me Spock for a
reason if first of all if you
self-described a Spock you're a douche
bag of epic magnitude my goodness really
if you go around you're like you know
what I am I'm like data you know what
I'm like Spock
that's me like when I make jokes about
that their jokes okay like when I say
that I'm a computer that's because I am
mocking myself okay when Trump says that
when Obama says that he is like Spock he
actually thinks of himself he is
epically rationally it really he says I
believe in reason and logic and all
these enlightenment values uh-huh but
the thing that we really have to invest
in is people we got to figure out a way
to work together and then he says that
the people who the the the people who
disagree with him have all of these
issues unfortunately that is an attitude
that has infused the Democratic Party
and it's very unified Democratic Party
it's a unified political
clever Democratic parties we're looking
at a real phenomenon in the Democratic
Party that is dangerous to the heart and
soul of the country because I think that
Obama's statements basically reflect the
view of a lot of folks on the Left which
is that if you disagree with them you're
inherently a bad races stupid human
being with mommy issues
they and I will say that they are
effective politically in a way that
Republicans have not historically been
I'll give you the evidence of that in
just one second so the best evidence
that Democrats are politically effective
is Nancy Pelosi so Nancy Pelosi this is
really amazing Nancy Pelosi that she was
receiving the challenge from a woman
named Marcia fudge who is a Democrat
from the state of Ohio a black Democrat
from the state of Ohio and she was going
to challenge Nancy Pelosi then it turned
out she was no longer going to challenge
Nancy Pelosi why because Nancy Pelosi
went full horse head in the bed with
Marcia fudge and she chopped off that
race horse's head and shoved it in
Marcia fudge his bed and then she
started Marcia fudge started screaming
that she would support Nancy Pelosi why
because within days of Marcia fudge
announcing that she might run against
Nancy Pelosi the local media uncovered a
letter written in 2015 by Marcia fudge
in support of a Cleveland judge named
named Lance Mason hey that specific
letter was a commendation write
recommending that his sentencing in a
case of violently beating his wife was
what the sentencing be lightened she
said I commend lands for immediately
recognizing that he needed help and
entering counseling which continues as
with this writing Lance accepts full
responsibility for his actions and has
assured me that something like this will
never happen again there was only one
problem with the letter beyond the
obvious of you know supporting a wife
beater it turns out that Lance Mason has
now been arrested for killing his wife
okay so that was not good it turns out
that he was convicted of beating his
wife in 2015 and he was arrested on
suspicion of murdering her on Saturday
and Marcia fudge had written a letter in
support of this guy well within hours it
turns out Marcia fudge now supports
Nancy Pelosi for Speaker of the House it
turns out members of the Democratic
Party pretty good when it comes to when
it comes to politics if they're both
good at politics and radical this is
very bad for Republicans conservatives
and mainstream Americans across the
political spectrum
now speaking of radicalism I would be
remiss if I did not point
out this insane story today okay nature
magazine has now come out with an
editorial nature magazine says that
gender sex is no longer connected with
genitals I am not kidding you this is
nature magazine so we found out last
week that the American Civil Liberties
Union does not care about civil
liberties that they want to make sure
that the title mine proposals by the
Trump administration never take effect
even though those title mine proposals
protect the rights of the accused they
said there are too many rights of the
accused the American Civil Liberties
Union now nature magazine which I was
led to believe by the name of their
magazine was interested in things like
say nature you know that it turns out no
not so much what they're really
interested in social science garbage
that is promulgated by the political
left cuz they hate President Trump this
is pretty amazing here's their editorial
in nature magazine according to a draft
memo leaked to the New York Times the US
Department of Health and Human Services
proposes to establish a legal definition
of whether someone is male or female
they solely unmute immutably on the
genitals they are born with genetic
testing it says could be used to resolve
any ambiguity about external appearances
the move would make it easier for
institutions to receive federal funds
such as university and health programs
to discriminate against people on the
basis of their gender identity this is
the best part okay ready this is nature
magazine and then the proposal from the
Trump administration is we will go with
your genitals in order to establish
which sex you are which works in ninety
nine point six percent of cases it works
probably higher than a probably
ninety-nine point nine percent of cases
this is the this is what works ok then
if there's still ambiguity we'll do a
genetic test on you so let's say they of
Klinefelter syndrome let's say that you
have xx Y right let's say that you have
a non functioning sry gene for example
on your Y chromosome let's say that all
of that happens we can then do a genetic
test and determine whether you're male
or female based on those genetics this
is part of the actual legislation
promulgated by the Trump administration
the regulation hey that is solely
scientific right there is there's a
scientific objectively verifiable test
being proposed by the Trump
administration here is what nature says
the proposal on which HHS officials have
refused to comment is a terrible idea
that should be killed off it has no
foundation in science and would undo
decades of progress on understanding sex
and gender a social construct related to
biological difference
but also rooted in culture societal
norms and individual behaviors biology
is not as straightforward as the
proposal suggests by some estimates as
many as 1 in 100 people have differences
or disorders of sex development such as
hormonal conditions genetic changes or
anatomical ambiguities some of which
mean that their genitalia cannot be
clearly classified as male or female
right which is why the proposal says
that you can do a genetic test as well
and then they just talk about a bunch of
cases in which like in in like 1980
where people miss assigned genitalia in
cases of intersex babies or something
even more scientifically complex is a
mismatch between gender and sex on a
person's birth certificate some evidence
suggests transgender identity has
genetic or hormonal roots but its exact
biological correlates are unclear
whatever the cause organizations such as
the Academy American Academy of
Pediatrics advise physicians to treat
people according to their preferred
gender regardless of appearance or
genetics so what there is no basis in
science this has no basis in science but
nature says that we are supposed to
pretend that science no longer exists
because Trump did it so well done nature
which no longer cares about nature
pretty amazing stuff ok you know we've
well let's do some things I like and
things I hate because I could go on
about this particular nature article all
day and in fact in the things I hate we
were going to get back to this topic in
which science has been used as a false
pathan bad science has been used as a
false baton to Club the unwilling into
submission at first let's do a couple of
things that I like so thing that I like
number one we've been doing William
Goldman stuff this week because he died
last week the book Marathon Man is
better than the movie marathon man so
the movie of Marathon Man is very famous
Laurence Olivier playing the Nazis L and
Dustin Hoffman playing his victim
basically the movies good Roy Scheider
is in it too it's it's a good movie the
book is actually better Marathon Man by
William Goldman go check out the book
check out the movie as well if you
haven't seen it it is quite good I think
the end is a little bit forced hey I
don't want to spoil it for people who
haven't actually seen it but both the
book and the movie are good William
Goldman very very talented guy ok other
stuff that other stuff that I like so
the Washington Post has another article
today another article today about what
sex was like behind the Iron Curtain I
am not kidding you this is like this is
like
the fourth article that The Washington
Post is written about why it was
actually not bad to be in a communist
country remember they did one on malice
China that Sexson Mao's China was
awesome you know with all the forced
abortion and the slave labor and such
well now they're saying that sex behind
the iron curtain was amazing and they go
back and they uncover a book there's a
full article about a book published in
1969 about is basically a porn book from
1969 that was distributed in Bulgaria
and this means that communism was kind
of Awesome or something it is a long
article in The Washington Post it says
it turns out there was plenty of sex
happening on the other side of the Iron
Curtain
although the openness of the public
discussion around it vary dramatically
from country to country and at different
periods of time but even in the prudish
Soviet Union people found their own ways
to have fun why is this necessary
hey throughout human history people have
found a way to have sex with people
really I'm in that difficult actually
but they now have to do revisionist
history where the Soviet Union was that
like it was secretly taboo and that made
the sex even more awesome I mean listen
to this today historians are uncovering
a wide diversity of sex educational
practices across the former Eastern Bloc
the poles had their all of their own
popular sex manual the art of loving
which sold over seven million copies
after its first publication in 1978 the
Yugoslavs actually had a Raj erotic
magazines including chick which targeted
youth and start now you could swap
version of Playboy well it is true that
Soviet citizens lived in a much more
conservative amorous culture the East
Germans and Czechoslovakian sex-positive
nations where leaders believed that
improved intimacy constituted a unique
benefit of life in non capitalist
societies oh my god so the forced
repression of hundreds of millions of
people was cool because they found some
porn manuals in Czechoslovakia circa
well done Washington Post I put it in
things I like because once again it
demonstrates that the media are off
their rocker okay time for a couple of
things at that I hate
okay so thing that I hate number one
there's an awful story from the Daily
Mail that of course has received no
mainstream coverage outside the Daily
Mail because it's too politically
incorrect according to the Daily Mail
there's a teacher who is now saying that
vulnerable populations of school
children particularly kids with autism
are being convinced by teachers that
they are transgender hey here's the
article from The Daily Mail and on an
astonishing 17 pupils at a single
British school are in the process of
changing gender the male can reveal most
of the youngsters undergoing the
transformation are autistic according to
a teacher there who said vulnerable
children with mental health problems or
being tricked into believing they're the
wrong sex the whistleblower says few of
the transgender children are suffering
from gender dysphoria the medical term
for someone who feels they were born in
the wrong body but are just as easily
influenced latching onto the mistaken
belief they're the wrong sex is a way of
coping with the problems caused by
autism earlier this year the male
revealed that a third of youngsters
referred to the NHS is only gender
identity clinic for children should
moderate-to-severe autistic traits it
means that 150 autistic teenagers were
given puberty brought block or drugs
which stopped the body from maturing the
teacher says she felt compelled to speak
out to protect pupils many of whom she
believes could already be taking the
powerful drugs and may go on to have
life-changing surgery she believes
schools and some politicians have
swallowed hook line and sinker a
politically correct fallacy peddled by a
powerful transgender Lobby she was
advised to keep parents and other
teachers in the dark if a pupil claimed
to be transgender older people's at her
school who changed and her grooms
younger mainly autistic students to do
the same one autistic teenager
is soon to have a double mastectomy this
follows hard on the heels of that insane
story in which a study that was
originally published by brown talked
about the possibility that kids who hung
out in groups where kids were glorifying
transgenderism actually turned out at a
disproportionate rate to be transgender
shocker shocker right it's not
biological there would be social
environments actually contributing to
how people think of themselves which is
not unusual social environment
contributes to how we all think of
ourselves this would just be the most
powerful outlier result of your peer
group helping you define who you are
okay that that's a dangerous thing when
you were talking about doing permanent
physical damage to your body
this study won't be covered we won't
hear any more about that Brown study of
course because we are supposed to
believe the transition
is an innate biological feature that
there's no proof for but it's an innate
biological feature that we are supposed
to say was born into now it may be true
that for certain transgender individuals
there's a biological component to their
gender identity disorder why not that
makes sense but the idea that everyone
who believes they're transgender is
being is is basically a woman in a man's
body there is no biological evidence for
and the idea that everyone who now
identifies as transgender is doing so
specifically because of immutable
immutable biological principles and not
environmental pressure or social peer
groups is not backed by science it's
simply not scientific okay other things
that I hate today
this is a story about Amber Tamblyn
so Amber Tamblyn who supposedly is a
nice person on Sunday she did a reading
at vulture fest it was a feminist AF
reading at vulture fest which means it's
just a delight I mean that's where I
would go for fun
wouldn't you be feminist AF reading at
vulture fest sounds awesome
the only thing that sounds better is
clocking yourself in the head with a
mallet repeatedly The Hollywood Reporter
framed Hamlin's reading is an emotional
story about election night she read from
her upcoming political memoir era of
ignition coming of age in a time of rage
and revolution detailing her political
awakening because I definitely need to
hear a lot about the political awakening
of an actress I can't believe it a
political a political awakening from an
actress who moved to the left crazy I
know never happened before in Hollywood
a young actress moving to the left and
hot no no Katy Perry was there obviously
so was America Ferrera and comedian Amy
Schumer on election night
Tamlyn was pregnant with her daughter at
the time and she said i swigged some
more zantac and my baby shoved her foot
into my ribs as if to foreshadow the
pain that was yet to come and she has a
dark realization swallowed me I was
going to bring a baby into this world
and not just any baby a girl she said
she imagined giving her daughter to
Canadians or Swedes to protect her from
whatever damage she believed president
from to would do to the country so and
then she apparently said she's at a
subway station that after the election
and started experiencing pain and
shortness of breath and she said she
collapsed in a homeless man offered to
cut the umbilical cord if she was going
into labor instead she was just having a
panic attack because
I'm Amber Tamblyn super-wealthy doing
just fine has Trump come for her come
for her daughter nope
I have a I have to agree I so I sort of
agree with Amber Tamblyn if you're a
person who wants to give away your child
to another country because a person of
the opposing party was elected as
happens pretty much every eight years in
this country then I think you should
also give your child to a foreign
country or to a parent who is not you
because you seem like a crazy person
this is a general rule of thumb when
Obama was elected and I had I had one
kid during and well I had two kids
during Obama's tenure neither time did I
say you know what Barack Obama's
president I wish I could just give these
kids to a poor sheep farming family in
New Zealand because Obama's president
because that would have been crazy about
liberals do this and they go and read at
the feminist AF vulture fest and they
are praised by The Hollywood Reporter
for it the genius the genius of these
folks okay time for a quick Federalist
paper since we haven't done one in a
couple of weeks there now in Federalist
50 making steady progress all the way
through the Federalist Papers this one
is written by James Madison then we can
sum it up pretty quickly
this particular Federalist paper is
about whether there ought to be periodic
revaluations of the Constitution like
should there be a provision in the
Constitution that says we'll get
together here every four years and
reconsider the Constitution his argument
is that it would undermine the
continuity of the Constitution and the
faith that we have in the sanctity of
the Constitution to be rewriting it
every four years or so he is he also
says that when you make it a regular
thing then there will be a partisan
breakdown in terms of the in terms of
the Constitution itself and it will just
turn into a partisan gridlock instead of
allowing organically consensus to form
about what needs to change in the
Constitution and you need that sort of
consensus for these amendments to
actually pass in the first place he
points to the example of the night.the
1783 1784 Pennsylvania Constitution
which did include a provision like this
he says is it is it to be presumed that
in any future cept any alep 'ok the same
state will be free from parties is it to
be presumed that any other state at the
same or any other given period will be
exempt from them such an event either be
presumed or desired because an
extinction of parties necessarily
implies either a universal alarm for the
public safety or an absolute extinction
of Liberty what he's saying there is
that you want the existence of people
who disagree with each other but you
don't want that being fought on the
basis of the Constitution every four
years at least not with regard to
revising the Constitution because that
will polarize as he
more instead you want a constitution
that unites us and political arguments
that divide us right that would be the
ideal okay well I hope that you have a
wonderful Thanksgiving and you have a
lot to be thankful for in this the
greatest country in the history of the
world there's a lot to be grateful for
forget about politics for just a second
and remember that you got to practice
the religion of your choice in this
country you get to speak freely you get
to live in prosperity economically
speaking you are the richest people in
the history of the world everything is
pretty good so cool down everything's
fine
enjoy and thank God for all the
privileges and benefits we have as
citizens of the greatest country in the
history of the planet I'm Ben Shapiro
we'll see you here next week is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Jess wah of era
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright
Ford publishing 2018